many Somalians have personally called me
to encourage me to speak to the US
government and to help Somalia they
wanted to know with the US government
will do my answer to Somalians was the
US government will only do what
Somalians in the US tell them to
do they will do what we want and nothing
else they must follow our orders we
Somalians must have that confidence in
ourselves we live in the US pay taxes in
the US have a real voice us is a country
where one of your daughters is a
congressman to to represent your
interests Somalia will never be in
danger as long as I'm in the US
Congress the US would not dare to
support anyone against Somalia to steal
our land sleep and comfort knowing I'm
here to protect the interests of Somalia
from inside the US system that's what
I'm doing here in Congress I'm here to
protect Somalia this is the best
argument for restricting immigration
that I have heard in years maybe that
I've ever heard